tabbat on va rester dans le sujet on va
faire une interview prise de tête
coc
bien alors je vais répondre brièvement
sur des sujets graves
c'est bien jean marie c'est bien c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles je vous
admire je sais que vous ne bougez pas
par le bien êtes vous favorable à la
sexualité hors mariage ah bah oui parce
que on est on est pas à l'abri et puis
des fois c'est bien d'eux peut-être des
fois de toucher une autre peau une autre
paire de nichons un autre show pinette
nos traders un truc comme ça donc vous
êtes vous êtes favorable la sexualité
hors mariage
je suis favorable jeu jj set je suis un
pauvre chien bo aux rumeurs je pense que
faut pas engueulé sens sans son mari qu
dans la veste eu retrouve un préservatif
où s'annulent de faire une scène à son
mari parce que trompé sa femme avec un
breizh a rédigé une petite bêtise trompé
sa femme sans préservatif c'est une
grosse connerie et donc je dis moi j'ai
les couilles en tout cas de 10 ans bah
moi que je pars en tournée ma femme me
prépare ma valise le même et chemise mes
chaussettes mais slip qui elle me met
une petite boîte de préservatifs et
pourtant je ne trompe jamais ma femme
mais c'est pour le car elle est
favorable au divorce
bah je sais que ça peut arriver et si si
jamais c'est nécessaire bien sûr il faut
il faut le faire en ce qui me concerne
moi j'aime bien l'idée dans ma vie à moi
de mettre marié avec une femme et de ne
jamais la quitter jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours pour moi je trouve que c'est plus
+ amour à y passer
c'est plus bien est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à l'adoption d'enfants par dés
couples homosexuels voilà le lance pas
la team a fait nos téléphones au nom
voilà non non non oui mais non
maintenant je peux développer un petit
peu maintenant il ya un truc est
formidable avec le pack si jamais tu dis
par exemple que tu es contre le pacs tu
passe pour un homme peuvent tout le
monde chi dans son froc on veut pas être
mais fun moi je suis pas homophobe vous
trouvez peut-être que l'homosexualité
était plus sexy du temps on était
sulfureux c'était plus sexy jean genet
que les petits couples qui vont faire
les courses ensemble chez auchan de
matin je dis simplement que la
république
n'importe quel gouvernement nous en tout
cas la république un général n'a pas
validé ce n'est pas le travail de la
république de valider une tendance
sexuelle ce n'est pas un troisième sexe
d'être aussi fait ça concerne d'ailleurs
à 80% les hommes déjà faut le dire c'est
pas un truc qui concerne pas les autres
et simplement j'ai dit en déconnant à
tous mes copains homosexuel je le redis
les jours on n'en dormira un enfant tu
sers lui disant et le prince charmant
embrassa le prince charmant
il ne se marièrent bas ils n'eurent pas
d'enfant puisqu'il se bourrer r le cul
alors jours mais ils vécurent heureux
ceci dit je n'ai rien je n'ai rien du
tout vraiment encore une fois je le
répète parce que c'est hyper dangereux
de parler de ça parce que c'est la
vieille crainte d'être de se retrouver
homophobes non le trou de balle c'est
une zone érogène formidable et tout
quand on passe un peu le doigt sur le
trop de mal c'est génial ça peut même
des fois de sauver d'une demi mal j'ai
donc moi je suis pas du tout ennemi du
dialogue au contraire bien mais ça c'est
fait alors alors qu'est ce qui arrive de
toi tu voulais la réaction de vidy c'est
ce que vous êtes pour l'adoption
d'enfants par les couples homosexuels
bien sûr et puis n'est-ce pas à la
république a décidé de quoi que ce soit
je te parle d'amour quand on parle
d'enfants à la fota république
un jeu qui dit non mais quatre ans parle
d'amour et les enfants en ont à [ __ ]
glück la république elle n'a pas à
défendre une tendance soit instauré une
tangente à un moment j'ai pas me poser
la question est ce que la république est
d'accord à ce que le bon dieu est
d'accord à ce que est ce que machin est
d'accord on s'en fout de la république
et les enfants sont jeunes enfants il
doit demeurer un train à mon avis doit
être élevée entre un homme et une femme
c'est quand même le mieux pour moi c'est
là c'est la normalité
parce que je ne dis pas que de temps
aussi ça c'est anormal junique c'est une
originalité et quant à tiger aussi
reconnaître mieux ça que c'est le gamin
il est avec le pas en compte et de mec
deux êtres fantastiques peut-être que là
dans ce cas précis ça peut être mieux
bien sûr mais je moi je parle pas là on
parle de théories évidemment on est sur
le papier
sur le papier je dis que
l'épanouissement d'un enfants élevés par
deux hommes je pense que c'est moins
bien qu'un homme et une femme
j'ai le droit de penser ça comme bien
sûr bien alors jean marie en continu
l'interview prise vas-y vas-y continue
l'avortement pour moi l'âme n'est pas
arrivé dans le foetus avant au moins six
mois et il n'y a pas une destruction
d'une personne c'est certain c'est un
embryon pour ceux qui pensent qu'ils ont
détruit une personne je pense pas que ce
soit le cas ça n'est pas suffisamment
formés d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'on
peut pas sortir un bébé du ventre de sa
mère à deux mois et le faire vivre parce
qu'il n'a pas d'existence hooper
l'euthanasie l'euthanasie je suis contre
parce que je pense que
il faut même si les souffrances sont
terribles je pense qu'il faut les vivre
jusqu'au bout et que comme je crois pas
au hasard encore une fois je pense que
il ya 10 à différents cas de figure ils
étaient les gens par exemple la
technique peut permettre de rester de
laisser brancher quelqu'un et de le
faire vivre même contre sable c'est à
dire que naturellement il n'aurait pas
vécu et il serait mort donc après le
fait de débrancher quelqu'un qui a le
cerveau totalement mort c'est très c'est
différent mais je parle l'euthanasie
c'est à dire donner la mort c'est pas
retirer un médicament c'est différent
retirer un truc qui fait vivre c'est
différent de donner la mort mais donner
la mort non la peine de mort pour les
assassins enfants vous d'accord dit le
mot enfant tout le monde a envie de tuer
tout le monde
si on tue ton enfant sous ses yeux la
peine de mort tu vas pas attendre que
les jurés délibèrent tu vas mettre
suscite un pistolet dans la main tu vas
tu risques de la donner la mort
effectivement dans tous les cas de
figure je peux je pourrai jamais dire
que je cautionne la mort est encore une
fois comme le pacs
quand c'est la loi qui décide de dire
voilà on va prendre tel individu et on
va le tuer ouais c'est injouable
personne ne peut voter une loi comme ça
en revanche ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
tout le monde est à peu près d'accord
tout le monde mais une grosse majorité
des gens sont d'accord que quand il ya
des attaches pris dans un avion tu as
des mecs du gign ils se font avec une
paire de couilles énorme comme ça et qui
ont un hommage d'ailleurs il rentre il
canarde et y tue les mecs et tout le
monde dit bravo
et là il n'ya pas de tribunaux il n'ya
rien du tour décide de la peine de mort
un mec rentrent dans une école barre des
dynamites comme anaïs rend ton lui-même
ballan citron et moi j'applaudis bas on
a voté la peine de mort on est tous
d'accord par quelques trous du cul qui
dit on aurait peut-être pu le garder en
vie mais moi mais moi moi je dis non
parce que moi je dis que si un mec
rentrer dans une maternelle avec un
paquet de dynamite sur lui si ce mec
risque la vie de trente enfants qu'il
risque pour moi sa vie et personne ne me
contredira en disant que depuis
l'attaqué qui a été fait sur l'avion n'y
a plus jamais de détournement il y en
avait
il y en avait 1 tous les tous les six
mois il y en a pu parce que on se dit
merde si je fais ça c'est la mort sûre
et certaine
donc je suis partagé entre les deux je
ne la gagne je n'aurais pas je ne dirais
pas qu'il faut aller la donner ouais
mais en revanche la loi c'est très très
dur parce que ce qui est écrit encore
une fois c'est exactement le thème de ce
qu'en disait tout à l'heure ce qui est
écrit n'est pas valable
il ya une loi pour chaque situation 4 le
mec soulager un mec qui piquent trois
pizzas entendu ça et si tu fais trois
délits d'un certain d'un dans certains
états des états unis trois fois le même
délit perpétuité cd c'est un sketch si
je me mets avec le nom on fait un sketch
et c'est le mec qui piquent trois pizzas
y prend perpétuité il ya un juge avec
des mecs qui sont là le juge il rentre
chez lui dit à sa femme chérie j'ai fait
mon travail aujourd'hui il ya un mais
qu'il avait piqué trois pizzas gmi
perpète
et tout le monde me regarde dans le plus
grand pays du monde c'est à dire que ce
euros il y conte le mec sait s'il prend
une quiche
il est chef qu'il échappe à perpète
il peut en plus si je mets si jamais ils
veulent les trois pizzas d'un coup élan
congèle 2 pour lui ça il fera pareil le
préjudice est le même bon le mec il va
pas en prison
comment est-ce qu'on peut cautionner les
lois comme ça c'est la loi du coeur qui
fonctionne et c'est comme ça que
j'essaye de répondre à tes [ __ ] de bon
la légalisation de la légalisation des
drogues douces vous demande pas si vous
êtes d'accord
la légalisation des drogues douces oui
oui bien sûr alors j ai la libération de
maurice papon alors la libération devant
il se bat pau c'est à mourir de rire
moi j'aimais bien badinter je laime bull
maintenant balle à terre il nous dira
papon et les vieux et tout ce pas utile
de laisser en prison dont il écrit mme
crimes contre l'humanité et ce mec
président crimes contre l'humanité il ya
crime il ya aussi humanité ouais non
mais oui d'accord mais seulement ce mec
on aurait préféré l'enfermer quand il
était jeune on arrête
mais on l'a eue que vieux et on leur
ferme en leur ferme vieux et malade et
en plus on l'enfer pour le laisse
observer et en plus j'ai dit que c'est
vachement sympa d'être en prison vieux
et malade
ouais ce qui était à l'infirmerie tu
gâches pas tes belles années c'est mieux
mais ça veut dire quoi de libérer un mec
ça veut dire que bon bah c'est fini non
non non c'est pas possible il faut se
garder en prison à moi je pense qu on le
garde en prison il a failli les juger il
prend des années de prison mexico à
l'histoire que tonga s'ils veulent un
scooter on le colle en le collant
grêlons kata mais qu'il a il a tué notre
personne et tout bas on le met en prison
aussi et puis si c'est un homme
d'affaires qui gruge des trucs et bat
aussi est le fils mitterrand comme
madame mitterrand elle dit j'ai payé la
rançon là ensemble j'aurais demandé 15
millions 1
là on pas y'a pas de rançon le mec qu'on
lui reproche pas doit déjouer les gens
dans le vi mitterrand dire il me regarde
avec de la haine dans les yeux ils te
regardent comme il veut qu est ce que tu
en as avant les sites à rien est
reproché il peut être regardée comme il
a bien sûr donc est donc ce juge moi je
trouve je trouve génial jeu pour moi je
le trouve génial parce que même pierre
botton j'ai vu une interview et lui
aussi je les trouve formidable parce
qu'il est directement
il vous a enfermé vous ai tout prix et
où il dit ouais mais au bout du compte
je pense qu'il m'a remis sur les sur les
rails et n'a jamais attaqué pour quelque
chose que j'ai à la fin un enchaînement
formidable parce qu'on va recevoir la
femme de pierre botton